I'm currently deployed to Iraq as an east six in the army.
I've listened to your podcast and really enjoy your stuff,
especially different discipline equals real.
I know as a sergeant and as a leader,
your focus isn't to be liked.
However,
your soldiers should respect you.
Respect both you and your rank.
My question is,
how do you tell your soldiers to do the small stuff?
Tedious stuff like taking out the trash and still be like,
all right,
well,
first of all,
if we want to get respect from people,
we have to give them respect.
For sure.
Think about this.
Think if you took out the trash for some time.
You don't think.
If you're the,
you're the boss,
but you see that the trash is getting overfilled and you just grab it and take
it out.
There's think about what that does.
Think about what that does.
The attitude of the guys.
If you took out the trash you,
you maybe in your mind you think you'd be losing respect,
but you actually wouldn't be at all.
In fact,
everyone looks at you and goes,
oh,
he's a good guy.
He's taken out the trash,
it was little full that he's taken care of it.
So maybe if you're insecure you'd think you'd lose respect.
But I think if you're secure in your ability to lead and if you know that doing
some tedious stuff is gonna make you guys appreciate you,
then to me that means it's kind of worth it.
Yeah.
Right.
Um,
another example,
you know we talked about taking all the trash,
but like what if the platoon space has to be cleaned
and on Friday you,
you just say,
hey guys,
you guys can go ahead and roll out.
I got this
right.
There's a chance.
They're like,
hey boss,
we're not leaving.
We know.
We'll help you there.
There's of course there's a chance you'd be like,
oh,
that's awesome.
Thanks boss.
And they bail
overtime.
That might be [inaudible].
If they don't respect you at all,
they might bail now in order to regain the respect,
the you make them stay in Boston around more.
Does that increase the respect for you?
You see,
you see how interesting it is is that if you go,
hey guys,
that's cool,
I'll do it.
And you're working hard and you still got to maintain the discipline and you
don't take any slack.
But at the,
it's the same balance,
the balance we talk about all the time.
So
the more that you treat them with respect,
the more they're gonna respect you and they're going to know that you're not,
you know,
too high and mighty,
they're going to know that you're down to earth.
When I was a platoon commander,
tasking to commander,
I picked up brass,
I cleaned the ranges with the boys.
That's just the way I operated.
And I would recommend that kind of attitude.
It didn't make people think,
oh,
Jockos doesn't have anything better to do.
They actually knew I had stuff to do,
but what I've got to do,
pick up brass with the boys,
build the relationships,
set the example.
Yeah.
They're gonna respect you for it.
Yeah,
makes sense.
At the end of the day,
do you have something better to do?
Right.
Because the whole,
in the big picture,
it's like how you say like that's a leader.
It's like sometimes you literally have something then no,
no.
Like,
sometimes you literally like,
Hey,
the boys are picking a brass and guess what?
You got to meeting with the commanding officer.
You gotta go,
do you,
you know,
sometimes we,
you actually do.
And what's cool is tactically is,
and you heard us saying this at the uh,
FTX and we're up in Utah.
If you see the leader doing something menial,
what you should do as a,
as a followers step up and say,
hey echo,
I got this.
You can go and lead.
That's what,
that's what you want.
That's what I want to do for my leader.
I want to take things off my leader's plate as much as possible.
Now
the more you try and you just have to build those relationships,
the way you build those,
if you don't have anything better to do,
then you get down there and you help you help clean up the range,
you help pick up the brass.
That's the way it is.
I actually did notice that about you and life to where,
you know,
like I'll have my camera equipment and you know,
lights or whatever and it's not a bunch of stuff.
But you know,
you're always like,
oh,
you'll like grab something and you don't like your camera.
Yeah,
don't touch,
don't touch.
But [inaudible] when it's just me and you,
it's kind of like cool cause we're just kind of friends or whatever.
There's no perceived or no like hierarchy kind of thing.
Like you're,
you know,
but let's say like at the muster,
whatever,
it's obviously like you guys have a,
a specific job.
I have a specific job,
you know,
kind of thing.
And meanwhile you n and life will like if I'm around,
I'm carrying something,
you'll always like grab something or,
or say,
hey you need,
you know that though at the Utah thing it's like,
Oh are you good?
I'm like,
Bro,
you're the instructor here kind of thing.
That's what I'm thinking in my head.
And um,
and yeah,
you guys always offered it like help.
Interesting.
I'm like almost offended.
Like Bro,
like do I look like I need help?
Cause you shouldn't really be asking me
very capable individual.
Yeah.
And
this small tedious stuff.
And the other thing is you explained to him why it's important,
right.
Not to answer.
We give all the time.
Why is it important?
Why is it important that the platoon huts clean?
Well,
because I want you guys to have time off over the weekends and not be stuck here
cleaning.
Cause the commanding officer came in and saw that this place looked like a hell
hole.
Okay,
well that makes sense to us.
We understand why you want us to clean now you want us to clean so that we can
have time off.
You want us to clean?
So you want us to train hard?
Do you want us to do this?
Cause?
Cause we want to be ready for combat cause I want you guys to be able to come
home to your families.
Make sure they understand why they're doing what they're doing.
And if there's no reason why to,
if the reason let mean even cleaning,
even taken out the trash,
there's a reason for that,
right?
There's an actual reason for that.
We can't just have junk everywhere.
So explain why participate when you can build the relationships with your
troops,
you'll be good.